just a few short hours ago one man set
up a camera to review movie this is that
footage Apollo 18 and yeah I'm not going
to keep that effect on the whole time
some of you may think you want it but
it's kind of like electing a president
at first you're like oh yeah that's a
good idea and then you know three four
saying you liked it and yeah that
actually sucks trust me so Apollo 18 is
the latest in one of these found-footage
kind of movies which these days they're
like a dime a dozen like 10 years ago
they were just unique as hell now
they're everywhere it is his own genre
now but as the Apollo missions have gone
we've sent up 17 of them and supposedly
never an eighteenth but now they have
the footage and they're going to show us
there was an 18th mission and this is
why we never went back which is funny
because this summer we already found out
why we never went back decepticons I got
the footage right here yeah check that
[ __ ] out there it is Sentinel Prime and
all that you laid on the draw man which
no matter where you're from Decepticons
Trump little creepy moon crabs any day
of the week and yeah that's will there
on this one the little creepy moon crabs
you saw him in the trailer was crawling
through the guy's face mask you don't
really get a good look at him but best
you can figure so the rachni that you
saved in Mass Effect one so if you have
a shot in Mass Effect one to kill these
things do it so the Apollo 18 crew can
rest happy and yeah they're like get
inside your body and they drive you mad
and we all knew it was gonna be like
that because the trailer showed that and
that's what these things do in these
kind of movies when you have a small set
a small budget and a small crew and you
can't get a good look at the aliens it's
alright just make one of the crew go
crazy because of the aliens and it's
done it's a done deal and the thing
about these found-footage movies is that
they're actually really slow and I'll
admit that I like the found-footage
movies but they are slow so you have to
be really interested in the subject at
hand I myself like outer space the moon
planets all that kind of stuff but this
movies not for everybody it'll bore the
[ __ ] out of like 90% of the population I
mean quarantine I thought was better
than this Cloverfield better than this
paranormal activity a lot better than
this I mean it does its job well it
making you feel like you're actually
watching found footage you know it's
nothing new if you don't like to found
footage movies now this is not going to
be the one to bring you over to the side
you're not gonna watch Apollo 18 and be
like I see now what I've been missing
it's like all clear it's not gonna
happen not with this one if it didn't
happen with Paranormal Activity it ain't
happening now the movie wasn't that
creepy I mean in Paranormal Activity
this team is like harassing people in
their beds we all sleep in beds so we're
all like oh dude I've been there I'm now
an astronaut I've never been to the moon
I'm never going to the moon space crabs
are like the least of my worries and
they should be the least of yours too if
they're not the least of your worries I
want your life that sounds exciting as
hell it's nothing new it's not as
exciting as a lot of the other
found-footage movies it's not original
by now it's not really menacing I jumped
a couple times that was because it jump
scares me you know I hate that [ __ ] in
the end it's alright but you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus one night
with the moon logo because I'm theme
Attic like that and kind of cheesy
sometimes but I'll tell you this they
build this really legit looking moon set
and they film it to look like it's 1970
something if the conspiracy theorists
were blogging before about how we never
landed on the moon it was all set yeah
they ain't stopping now alright so
found-footage movies what's your
favorite found footage movie comment
below let me know in any case if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more